what's up everyone at meet delic
my name is jason silva i'm so sorry i
can't be with you guys
in person but through the magic of
information technology which is itself
psychedelic i am beaming this
transmission from across the world to
share my vision of the future of
psychedelics and
healing
now where does this begin for me
my friends well this of course begins
with my interest in alleviating human
suffering this begins with a desire to
understand
the existential weight of our traumas my
desire to
mend our broken psyches because the
mental
health epidemic friends is real and it
is
it is inconceivable to me that we don't
declare this a public health emergency
according to the world health
organization and this is a astonishing
figure around 800 000 people a year now
are committing suicide that is a larger
number than the amount of people that
die from armed conflict and natural
disasters combined so that means that
our own psyches our own
minds are more dangerous to our
lives than natural disasters and armed
conflict now of course climate change is
an emergency and of course we want to do
our best to end wars and violent
conflict across the world but we really
need to address this mental health
epidemic that is causing so many people
to take their
lives the status quo friends isn't
working anymore and it's not just those
that have taken their lives it is all of
us who suffer under the weight of
anxiety of depression of post-traumatic
stress disorder it is all of us that are
carrying the scars of trauma and that
are too ashamed and feel so impotent we
know not what to do we need new answers
we also need better questions and this
is really where psychedelics are
potentially so game changing right
psychedelics
psychoactive compounds they seem to
provide
a unique intervention
that
literally transforms us from within and
how this works of course is the most
interesting story of our age as we live
through this psychedelic renaissance and
as more and more people start to kind of
join the train that's left the station
it's more important than ever to
understand how psychedelics do what they
do
why they do what they do and then of
course imagine how we might deploy these
tools in conjunction with other ecstatic
and psychoactive technologies to create
spaces of healing and transformation
that reinvigorate and upend the human
condition it's not just about healing
our fractures but also as michael pollan
says about making well people better and
so on this note let us begin the story
of psychedelics my name is jason silva
let's get into it
so the most interesting thing of course
about psychedelics is the fact that
under controlled environments with the
right guard rails with the right
psychotherapists in the room with the
right protocols and procedures they have
an astonishing capacity to heal we're
talking people with treatment resistant
depression people with treatment
resistant anxiety people with
obsessive-compulsive disorder that
hasn't responded to any traditional
treatment finding absolution being
literally cured of their pathology by a
handful of psychedelic sessions now how
exactly does this work well i'm
particularly persuaded by the words of
robin carthart harris he's probably at
this event and he used to be at the
imperial college of london he's a
neuroscientist who's achieved great fame
for his
cutting edge research on psychedelics he
coined
what i think is a compelling theory of
mental illness called the entropic brain
theory why the entropic brain theory
well basically he says that
the worm at the core or rather the root
of all mental distress right whether
it's depression anxiety ocd ptsd and
others all of them actually originate in
the same dysfunction which is excessive
rumination a brain that has essentially
become too
ordered see unlike manic depression or
schizophrenia which are which are
pathologies of brain disorder
obsessions obsessive-compulsive disorder
ptsd anxiety and depression actually
stem from an excessively ordered brain a
brain that has become hyper vigilant a
brain that has
metastasized and and given rise to an
ego that has turned into a tyrant that's
the version of us that on the other side
of trauma has grown so hyper vigilant
that we live inside of this these
patterns of thinking this kind of locked
in syndrome of distress
that we're either we're either playing
back recurring stories of depression and
or anxiety obsessing with this excessive
rumination and self-conscious these
locked in patterns of thinking that we
can't seem to transcend or escape right
and so what's interesting then about
this entropic brain theory is that
psychedelics can address
all of these mental pathologies because
of the mechanism of action of
psychedelics which is incredibly
compelling so here's how they work for
those of us that are stuck in the rut of
obsessive thinking of excessive
rumination and self-consciousness think
of it as like i think robin carthart
harris explains it like like a ski
mountain and there's all these ski
routes down the mountain and they're
like the popular routes and everybody's
skiing down the same routes and after a
while these ski routes they get like
grooved like tire tracks and everybody
like the patterns in our thinking
everybody takes the same way down all
the time and for those of us on locked
in by patterns of thinking related to
trauma we keep thinking the same
thoughts we get stuck in the same
loops we're trapped in these stories
that no longer serve us right as a
definition i once read about a personal
crisis begins when the story you tell
yourself about yourself is no longer
convincing because human beings were
storytelling animals our sense of
meaning and signification and mental
health is sustained by a personal
narrative a story that tells us who we
are a mytho poetic story that sort of is
is aligned with our biographical reality
a sense of meaning but when that story
goes awry when we get locked into
patterns of thinking and self-defeating
narratives we're like stuck inside these
lenses of perception and psychedelics
essentially as robin carthart harris has
said they shake the snow globe
right and so in shaking the snow globe
you create a kind of tabula rasa what he
calls a pivotal mental state of
increased suggestibility and receptivity
whereby you can go in and do some
serious meta programming of the human
operating system you can craft a new
story a phoenix that rises from the
ashes of course
this
this experience of shaking the snow
globe and opening up a space where we
can go in and intervene and craft a new
story is what's known as the is what's
known as happening in the space of
what's called ego death or a mystical
experience right these are
subjective accounts of what it feels
like to die to your story and to create
a new story but the at the level of uh
what you might call mechanism of action
psychedelics do this of course by
engaging the serotonin to a receptor and
so on and so forth and dissolving
temporarily something called the default
mode network which is where you might
call the seat of the soul or the
autobiographical mind the ruminating
part of the neocortex the default mode
network is what has become overly active
and overly ordered in people who are
traumatized and in temporarily shutting
this down this physical mechanism of
action psychedelics provide finally a
place to rewrite that story and with the
right guard rails and with the right
interventions with the right therapist
and perhaps with the right music with
the right tools that pivotal mental
state is a unique opportunity to forge a
new sense of self to forge a new story
and this is hugely important but it's
important on two levels on the one hand
it's important to understand the
physical mechanism of action to
understand the science to understand the
thing we can measure in clinical trials
but on the other hand it's interesting
to speculate about the content of these
experiences what happens inside of us
how does this transformation play out
inside the waking dream that is a
psychedelic trip and how do we interpret
and integrate these trips
psychologically right ursula le guin
famous author she said it best she said
science describes accurately from the
outside and poetry describes accurately
from the inside science explicates and
poetry implicates it's like church and
state we need the science we need to
understand the mechanism of action we
need to ground these medicines in a
quantifiable reality that we can test in
a lab but we also need poetry and art
and music right we also need
interpretations for the interior
experience that defines the human
condition and be able to map those
spaces as well
and that happens to be a big passion of
mine i need to find that intersecting
point between physical mechanism of
action and mytho-poetic reality right
the consensus world that we live in and
the mythopoetic truth beyond the literal
grid where the human soul resides and it
is at this intersection that my work
comes most alive and so again it's all
about mechanism of action understanding
the science but also having the tools to
map those domains psychologically how we
heal from our trauma is as much a story
as it is a physical mechanism of action
that says oh yeah okay so he no longer
meets the criteria for depression or
anxiety because his serotonin levels are
balanced once more and so on and so
forth and that really my friends is what
it's all about
so
now what i'd like to do is show you a
video that attempts to map the
ineffability of the psychological
experience of ego death right because
now that we understand the mechanism of
action shaking the snow globe
temporarily shutting down the default
mode network and all that jazz and all
that
scientific jargon let's show you the
poetry let's show you the song from the
inside of what it's like to die to who
you were cleanse your lenses of
perception experience resurrection and
break on through to the other side this
friends is a video on ego death enjoy
let's talk a little bit about
experiences of ritualized
surrender
right psychologists often tell us that
it is in the act of letting go that you
find out who you are the prospect of ego
death however the prospect of any kind
of ritualized surrender
feels like dying but only to those who
resist it
those who eventually come to realize
that there is no such thing as death at
least that
psychological dying into the moment is
but an illusion the last hurrah the last
resistance before you hurl yourself into
the abyss and realize that it's a
feather bed
you know terence mckenna talked about
this he said this is the secret this is
what all the
the shamans the professors the wise men
this is what they understood this is the
alchemical goal this is how magic is
done you hurl yourself into the abyss
and you realize that
it's a featherbed
our society today is constructed we know
this in a way where many people are
afflicted with the pathological amount
of
anxiety and depression it's what jamie
weil calls 21st century normal this
fibrillating anxious state from an
overactive ego stemming from a misfiring
default mode network which is the
autobiographical mind which is
essentially metastasized into something
that is
a kind of autoimmune disorder of the
self and the excessive rumination and
self-consciousness that characterizes
depression and anxiety both come from a
mind that has become too ordered too
rigid too hyper vigilant it's like we're
all living with a perpetual micro ptsd
and what the research tells us and this
has informed so much of my creative life
what the research now
tells us is that in
safe containers and with the proper
precautions deployed the experience of
ecstatic surrender the experience of ego
death what jamie wheel calls the bliss
[ __ ] crucifixion is actually where all
the healing is done right it is when you
die into the moment that you realize
that all your fears are unfounded you
come to see that everything you want is
on the other side of fear right it's
like that david fincher movie the game
reveals to us in that line that says
quoting the bible john chapter 12 verse
something whereas once i was blind
now i can see
it is hard to put language to these
instances of ecstatic surrender right
hurling yourself into the abyss and
realizing that it's a feather bet
arrives you at a domain that exists
outside of
time
the self experiences this as liberation
from the incessant inner chatter we are
free to be ourselves we become
infinite is what it feels like
transitory enchanted moments in which we
hold our breath
compelled into aesthetic contemplations
we neither understand nor perhaps even
desired face to face with something
could measure it to our capacity
for wonder
we experience a fresh the hardly
bearable ecstasy of direct energy
exploding in our nerve endings
we recontextualize the self as a
marvelous conduit and timeless whole
from which molecules and meanings flow
from neurons to nebula and back again
we see the world in a grain of sand and
we see heaven in a wild flower we hold
infinity in the palms of our hand we
hold eternity
in an hour
[Music]
and then the moment will pass
and all contradictions are reconciled
man has surpassed the gods
you know what do we find
after these enchanted moments what do we
find after these moments of opiated
adjacency when we spill over when we
overflow when we are cracked open so
that the light gets in
we find that people report increased
feelings of well-being in their baseline
reality increased feelings of compassion
increased feelings of creativity
increased feelings of joy a sense of
having glimpsed
noetic truths
a sense of having tapped into the
infinite a feeling of communion
with
the cosmos
an ontological awakening a spiritual
experience a forceful reckoning with
what is
a mainlining of space and time through
the optic nerve
we become what we behold and we behold
the infinite
miguel dunamuna wrote in tragic sense of
life eternity eternity nothing is real
that is not eternal
so the question remains right we know
the way we know the past we know what we
must do to heal ourselves
how might we turn our passing
illuminations into abiding light
[Music]
how might we turn our self-systems from
leaky buckets
right colanders full of holes
into chalices
said jamie we how might we render
ourselves whole how might we render
ourselves
holy
this has become the central
preoccupation
of my life
all right now
it should be noted that i am an artist
and so my account of the inside of a
psychological ego death like what a
psychological ego death feels like from
the inside takes the poetic license
that an artist always takes so take it
with a grain of salt that is my poetry
that is my
song that is my attempt to language
the ineffable so much of what happens in
psychedelic space and so much of what we
might call psychological healing is a
highly personal experience we all have
different narratives we all have a
different story about who we are we all
have different belief systems we all
have different superstitions we all have
different
we all have a different meaning making
process and so it is my view that we
must be clear about the distinction
between what's true for us and what's
empirically or objectively real this is
part of the paradox of psychedelics that
we're trying to map in a lab and
quantify the healing effects of an
experience that itself seems like it
exceeds the literal grid you know when
people have a mystical experience on
psychedelics they feel like they
transcend their bodies they have an out
of body experience they connect with the
eternal they have a bleed through effect
that where they feel like they go
through through wormholes and transcend
space and time and see the divine and
engage with pachamama or jesus or buddha
or whatever interpretive framework they
have and so here you have an ex felt
experience that feels like it is
metaphysical and a world that asks us to
map this quantifiably because we have to
pass it through phase one phase two
phase three trials we need to meet the
criteria of the food and drug
administration and so on and so forth
and so what i would say
is i would echo the words of chris
lethebe chris lethebe is a natural
philosopher out of australia who
basically says that the content of the
psychedelic experience the highly
personalized interiority of a
psychedelic experience is like church
and the epistemic effects the thing that
we can measure in the world are you
better do you no longer meet the
criteria for depression do you no longer
meet the criteria for anxiety those
epistemic values are like state so we
should separate church and state when
you have a psychedelic experience and
you craft and disclose new psychological
truths about yourself that heal you
that's for you that's not scripture nor
should it be doctrine that's your poetry
that's what you journal that's what you
integrate and talk to your family about
that's the highly personal mythopoetic
interiority that is your psychology
that's your church and you should be
free to interpret the trip in the same
way that you are free to worship as you
wish
but the state but the science but the
epistemic value but the thing we measure
when we pass through clinical trials to
legalize these substances and make these
practices and protocols
available that just has to be
do you feel better
do you no longer meet the criteria for
depression are you serving your
community is your suicidal ideation gone
if those things are true then
psychedelics passed the test now if
you're still grappling with the fact
that you were like hovering through time
and space and you felt yourself dissolve
into molecules hey man write a poem
right write a journal entry make a song
make an art film show me what it was
like for you right that's the role of
art that's the role of artists right as
to
to to reflect our historical drive to
manifest
our interiority or our consciousness
outside of our mind in front of our eyes
and so my invitation to this audience as
we move into this psychedelic
renaissance and we work so
intensely to try to legalize these
compounds and make them accessible for
others is let's keep church and state
separately right let's not make any any
great statements about the interior
psychological experience let us not take
our own psychology and our own
interpretation and turn that into
scripture let us not turn this into a
cult let us not celebrate false gods and
false and false idols let us not have
ego inflation where we think because we
experience the powerful ego death that
now we know the answer that everyone
else should follow that's how we corrupt
the psychedelic revolution the magic of
your psychological experience take that
take your broken heart and turn it into
art take that healing and turn it into
art but what we measure in the lab the
case we make to governments across the
world the harm reduction and the power
of this revolution to alleviate
suffering that should be measured in
ways that everybody can agree on that's
consensus reality no more suicidal
ideation no more ptsd no more depression
no more anxiety an ability to function
in the world an ability to contribute to
our community if it meets all those
criteria then this psychedelic
revolution is here to stay
okay friends the human condition is no
small picnic we're all bearing the load
of being finite beings craving
immortality right the explicit awareness
that we're breathing pieces of
defecating meat destined to die and
potentially no more significant than a
lizard or a potato as sheldon solomon
says is no easy picnic we must craft new
interpretive frameworks that serve us
but we still cannot deny the reality of
being mortal beings so the human
condition
in itself causes a kind of micro ptsd
and perhaps psychedelics are the tools
that allow us to live with equanimity
and grace in spite of this horrendous
imposition called mortality perhaps they
are tools that endow us with grace and
fill us with faith two things with which
without i don't know if we can live
right they say that human beings can
live for a couple of uh a couple of
couple days without food and water but
we can't even live for a minute without
hope and perhaps the vision of these
psychedelic experiences can fill us with
the kind of hope that carries over into
our everyday lives what we see on those
peaks we can bring back into the valleys
and help our community and plant seeds
and serve others and show up and grow up
and get to work and so that's the
contemporary state of psychedelics and
uh
and that's really something i'm
immensely passionate about and so
in summation of the human condition and
the importance of these tools um
here's a beautiful video animated with
some oil paintings about what it means
to be human and how delicate it is
to be aware that we're aware
watch
human beings find themselves
in quite the predicament
we have the mental capacity
to ponder the infinite
seemingly capable of anything
yet we're housed in these heart-pumping
breath-gasping decaying bodies
simultaneously gods
and worms
human beings exist at the interplay
between the finite and
the infinite
the explicit awareness that you're a
breathing piece of defecating meat
destined to die
ultimately no more significant than a
lizard or a potato
is not especially uplifting
we are the only being in the animal
kingdom that can contemplate its own
death
so it's not just that we're running away
from immediate predators but that even
if everything's awesome we lose sleep
over the fact that one day
we will die one day the sun will eclipse
and burn the earth one day
it's all gonna end
but the existential bummer is that we
are uniquely aware
the first and most impactful solution to
the death problem was the virtual
reality known as religion
it absolves us of our fear because guess
what you'll live forever in the kingdom
of god
the second solution to the problem of
death
is romantic love the deification of the
other
the third solution to the problem of
death perhaps the most interesting one
the creative solution to the problem of
death
what can we build
what can we do
what can we create together to overcome
to transcend
to redefine our boundaries
to expand the perimeters of the possible
to overcome our limits to put things
together in a certain way
in which things become transcendent
[Music]
all right so i'd also like to say a few
words about
psychedelics as teaching tools
right how exactly is it that what you
might call psychedelic knowledge the
insights that
emerge or are disclosed in a psychedelic
state these flashes of revelation
how exactly does that work and why is it
that these flashes of revelation can get
through
right can be downloaded into our minds
hearts and bodies in ways that
conventional
knowledge seemingly cannot and for this
i turned back to mr chris lethebe neck
psychedelic naturalist out of australia
so
he talks of course about the infamous
lenses of perception echoing aldous
huxley's famous writing in the doors of
perception so chris says we have these
lenses of perception and these lenses of
perception are are interpretive
frameworks they are the augmented
reality that we deploy upon the world to
make sense of that world and those
lenses of perception are shaped by our
past history our biographical reality
our cultural upbringing the set of
experiences throughout our lives that
have created these maps of meaning and
interpretation that we use to read
with right to read the world with and
the interesting thing about these lenses
is they're so ever present that we
forget we're wearing them right like
like that's what's really the most
compelling thing we we see with these
lenses and we see through these lenses
but we're not aware we're wearing the
lenses we don't see the lenses
themselves so think about how
potentially problematic this is to see
with those lenses and through those
lenses but not be self-aware enough to
know that we're wearing lenses means
that when trauma happens to us that when
really bad things happen to us when the
involuntary killings of the ego and
humiliation and the circumstances and
tragedy of life happens to us that
affects our interpretive frameworks it
affects our maps it colors our lenses it
makes our lenses go black and so now
this trauma makes it so that everywhere
we look we see danger everywhere we look
it triggers hyper vigilance everywhere
we look we think everybody is
distrustful right because of our past
trauma the problem is just because
something bad happened in the past
doesn't think it's automatically going
to happen in the present or in the
future the nature of trauma as david
lansin says is that it's a kind of
temporal dislocation the past trauma
becomes the lenses that you bring to the
doorstep of every moment and so what
happens is you bring the past to the
present you overread or misread what's
happening now you over determine the
present and immediately conjure up a
future that becomes identified with
death and you can feel it like a fist in
the stomach and so the problem is when
you're stuck wearing these lenses that
are no longer serving you chris lethe
says you need an experience of what he
calls knowledge by acquaintance enter
psychedelics because knowledge by
description just won't work the pit of
despair of anxiety and depression and
ocd is that which is a space in which
language doesn't serve language doesn't
reach i can try to pull you out of that
dark hole by promising you a world on
the other side of transformation but
knowledge by description simply will not
get through you're too guarded you're
too locked up you're too locked in
but psychedelic psychedelic experiences
evoke again as robin carthart harris has
said these pivotal mental states and
when you're highly open and highly
suggestible instead of knowledge by
description you are shown knowledge by
acquaintance knowledge that hits in the
stomach in the heart and in the mind it
hits somatically they call it somatic
healing it's not just content that's
cognitive it's content that is in the
body and in the soul and in the psyche
and so this knowledge by acquaintance is
the metaphorical equivalent of taking
you out of that black hole and
helicoptering you to the top of mount
everest at sunrise while listening to
han zimmer as you are moved to the point
of tears and you kiss the one you love
you are shown the light even the bible
said whereas once i was blind
now i can see it is these flashes of
illumination that seem to
really make a deep shift in our psyches
and souls it is these flashes of
illumination of what the greeks call
catalepsis a truth from which nothing
can dislodge you that seem to lead to
the lasting transformation of
psychedelics and so again
psychedelics work psychedelics teach
psychologically through these
interpretations that are
disclosed when the lenses of perception
that you see through and that you see
with become readily apparent
like i was seeing the world through that
lens but now i can see the lens and that
lens is scratched and broken and it's
shaped by what happened in the past and
now i know that to be true so now i can
dispense of that lens and i can buy a
new pair of sunglasses a new pair of
lenses of perception a new pair a new
set of interpretive frameworks
new poetry new new inspirational quotes
a new life mission a new map for my
future and now i can bring that instead
to the doorstep of every moment thanks
to an experience of what you might call
inverse ptsd right the trauma that gave
you the darkness has now been
sort of sort of
has been absolved by an experience of
such radiance and beauty truth freedom
and love that i am no longer the same i
am better i am cured and that my friends
is knowledge by acquaintance and that my
friends is how psychedelics teach now
psychedelics heal
okay my friends my friends my friends at
meet deleg thank you for taking this
trip with me thank you for taking this
journey with me as we map the domains of
psychedelics and map where we're
currently at in this wonderful
renaissance now i'd like to speculate a
little bit about the future of
psychedelics because i am also a
futurist and i think a lot about
psychoactive technologies right we are
all i think ecstatic technicians of the
sacred now we're all increasingly having
the capacity to dj our own subjectivity
to engage the technical material of
subjectivity itself as eric davis says
because that evanescent flux of
sensation and perception that he writes
is all we have and all we are is
increasingly being able to be stewarded
as david lenson says true liberation is
stewardship of internal life and we have
the ecstatic technologies and
interventions and we have new exotic
technologies that are emerging that will
allow us to share spaces and places of
what you might call inter-subjectivity
that are also really compelling let's
talk about virtual reality or rather the
reality of the virtual because as i've
mentioned before
the way we see the world is a virtual
reality right it's a compelling
meta-narrative that we deploy upon the
world like a kind of augmented reality
so
everything from language to identity is
a virtual reality but that doesn't mean
it's fundamentally unreal the dream is
real when you're in it right if you
believe it to be true it becomes true
and when we join forces right you could
say that we scale the reality of this
dream a dreamy dream alone is just a
dream but a dream you dream together is
reality and so virtual reality as an
actual immersive technology mediated by
digital tech is really exciting because
as terence mckenna the psychedelic
philosopher wrote right now if i want to
show you my soul or show you my psyche
all i can really do
is make a painting or film or a video or
bring you into my room so you see my
books and my bed and my pillow and my
teddy bears right i can show you
artifacts that are intimations of my
inner life but that's fundamentally low
resolution as flo bear says even human
speech is like a cracked kettle on which
we tap crude rhythms while we long to
make music that will melt the stars so
how can i show you the music i have
inside of me that longs to melt the
stars well this is where virtual reality
potentially becomes interesting because
it's full flourishing might become
something on the level of neo in the
matrix where you follow the white rabbit
in fully immersive virtual spaces that
are as real as our incarnated reality
but in those spaces we could
turn our minds inside out terence
mckenna says intimacy will be when i can
invite you into my mind not just into my
room so when two people want to connect
they could show each other's souls to
one another potentially with brain
machine interfaces while tripping on
psychedelics mediated by virtual reality
now i'm geeking out here but try to
imagine what it must be like to show the
universe inside of you to somebody else
to hover and float through galaxies of
your own making
inside what you might call soul space or
inner space with somebody else it would
be true
intersubjectivity it would be two souls
becoming one it would be a shared mental
space a cosmology of two a shared
interiority where your insides and my
insides could finally become one
i for one am very excited to see what
this might look like and i hope that
i've inspired you not just with my tall
tale of the current state of things when
it comes to psychedelics but also to
invite you of what new exotic
interventions we could potentially
deploy to stored our minds into places
and spaces of what we might call
paradise engineering in the words of
david pierce let us paradise engineer a
world powered by mdma-like consciousness
fueled by psilocybin like ego death
inspired by cannabis like virginal
noticing and sense of first sight
unencumbered by knowingness as michael
pollan says let us combine all of these
psychoactive subjectivities and render a
place of mind and meaning where we
become art where we become poetry where
we become awe where our waking state is
one of such perceptual expansion that we
become like jodie foster at the end of
the movie contact when she gets
slingshotted through the wormhole
witnesses a celestial event
gets tears in her eyes and says they
should have sent a poet
they should have sent a poet
they should have sent a poet
thank you meet delic i'm jason silva
wish you a beautiful day